okay as we wrap up our uh sort of
internal conversation about yesterday's
first presidential debate between Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton later we'll
talk to luke vargas about some other
angles there's a short video that I'm
gonna play for you and this is from CBS
journalist Moshe I knew knew I i hope
i'm pronouncing the last name right uh
mr. ohh new new posted a video this is
from the spin room after the debate
where Donald Trump claimed that his mic
was defective he alluded to having been
given a defective microphone on purpose
during the debate it's a little bit hard
to hear it's very bizarre because you
could hear Trump perfectly fine during
the entire debate so wit where is this
defective Mike stuff coming from let's
take a listen
my day was fine I talked to this time
and they also have
my mind was effectively
but I had a bike that wasn't properly
did that explain this nipples and if you
look at all mr. Chandra Mike on the
simple yeah well that explains
everything a deliberately sabotage
microphone that no one else noticed was
problematic I guess when he says it was
not working well in the room maybe it
was working fine for the TV transmission
but for the monitors that were in the
room maybe it wasn't working nobody else
has up mirrored that sentiment this is
not the first time Trump is suggested
that there was a problem with
microphones and I thought but this has
to be a joke right he's kidding about
the mic problem but no apparently this
is real Donald Trump saying that he had
a defective microphone truly a master of
excuses it actually would have served
Donald Trump very well if his microphone
had been defective because nobody would
have heard the nonsense he said I would
argue had Trump had a defective
microphone he would have had a far
better performance than what he actually
had maybe he met that he had a defective
mind during the debate not a defective
Mike I don't know I can't figure out
what it is he was talking about when I
lose at a video game I claim that my
controller was defective you know if
you've been playing mario since you were
a kid you know that you can always go
with the my controller isn't working
right thing and that's why I wasn't able
to play well uh and Donald Trump
apparently using that same idea uh very
very strange and I've asked a bunch of
people who were in the room and I said
were you did you have trouble hearing
Donald Trump was there any reason to
think that his microphone was not
functioning properly or defective in
some way and the eight or nine people I
spoke to who were in that room all said
I don't know what on earth Donald Trump
is talking about I guess if there is a
chance that Trump will be President and
sadly there is uh it's good that we know
he can make excuses completely out of
thin air for anything that he messes up
because he would be messing up a lot of
stuff if you were President of the
United States send me your thoughts
about the debate i'm on twitter at d
pakman we will take a break and be back
with luke vargas after this
in fly is sort of like Netflix for video
games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / TDPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s